they call it the MQ-9 Reaper drone the
United States says that surveillance
craft was intercepted in international
airspace by Russian jets that dumped
fuel on it and caused it to crash in the
Black Sea
this hazardous episode is a part of a
pattern
of aggressive and risky and unsafe
actions
by Russian pilots in international
airspace
so make no mistake
the United States will continue to fly
and to operate wherever international
law allows
on the day Vladimir Putin welcomed
Syria's president to the Kremlin Moscow
wasn't entertaining the U.S version of
events
there have been close encounters over
the Black Sea before
on this occasion Russia says its Jets
were sent to intercept the Drone but
made no contact
as a result of a Sharp maneuver the MQ-9
drone went into unguided flight with a
loss of altitudes and crashed into the
sea I want to emphasize that the Russian
Fighters didn't use their weapons didn't
come into contact with the unmanned
aerial vehicle and they safely returned
to their base
Russia's Ambassador was summoned to the
U.S state Department as Washington
complained of a Brazen violation of
international law
Moscow said it planned to retrieve the
drone's wreckage and the Kremlin
spokesman described its relations with
the United States as deplorable at their
lowest point
the Grim fate of the MQ-9 Reaper further
darkens fraught diplomacy
James Matthews Sky News Washington